>> I think when people are choosing
between growth or monetization.
They think that decision applies
to every single kind of company.
And I think for
some companies it makes sense that
you're going to pursue growth.
And I think the way you're thinking
about growth is in terms of people who
decide to hold off on
monetization until later.
And usually that means that you have
to build some other kind of asset,
that allows you to sell.
So, for example, social networks
are the easiest one, right?
The thing you ultimately the way you're
going to monetize that is your audience
or your user base and that
information that you have from there.
And the only way you're going to get
that is if you have a large amount of
information.
And so you focus on growth in
regards to getting people and
getting people engaged and
what have you.
And then the monetization will
happen because you finally have
product market fit where advertisers
say, this is enough information or
data, this is enough audience that
we're willing to pay for this.
Most B2B companies or enterprise
companies, you don't think like that.
It's actually far more straightforward.
It's a one-to-one relationship.
I'm making something,
I'm making a service.
And on whatever parameters that you
think your paid upgrade trigger is,
whether it's convenience or
it helps you make more money or
it saves you on time or energy or
people or cost savings.
That one-to-one relationship is a lot
more straightforward and you can say oh,
that obviously it makes sense.
It's this for that.